after weeks of national trauma thousands
turned out to see Iran's supreme leader
in a rare show of strength the men
cheered and chanted as Ali huh many
railed against Iran's enemies spokesmen
for the wicked government of America
keeps saying that we are standing with
the Iranian people you are lying if you
do stand with the Iranian people it is
because you want to stick your poisoned
dagger into the chest of the Iranian
nation you haven't been able to do that
so far and you won't be able to do a
damn thing his intervention comes after
the country's top military commander was
killed by US forces earlier this month
triggering a nationwide outpouring of
grief and a tragic stampede which saw
scores killed then came what Iran said
was an accidental downing of a passenger
jet killing all 176 people on board
angry protests engulfed the capital
lamented the crash but said Iran was
being manipulated some people follow and
a guided by American televisions and
English radio that try to portray this
incident in such a way that the deaths
of these two martyrs would be forgotten
you message heard loud and clear by
President rouhani who sat among the
worshippers the ayatollahs presence
underscores the crisis the last time he
delivered Friday prayers in 2012 amid a
standoff over its nuclear weapons
program for more on this story we have a
senior journalist Dima tahini with us
from DW Arabic Dima thanks for joining
us thank you for having me the last time
that the Supreme Leader spoke at Friday
prayers was in 2012 why do you think he
chose to speak now and
do you think of what he said actually I
mean I appeared after eight years simply
because he has to he has to address all
the pressure we are talking about
international pressure and also domestic
pressure I will concentrate more on the
domestic pressure because it's more
important for coming I think in my own
opinion I mean there's anger over
downing of passenger plane there's also
anger over economic economical situation
and US sanctions there's anger over
killing Qasem Soleimani there's a lot of
anger there so basically he's stepping
in after ATH to say I'm still in power
I'm still there because there were
speculations and rumors about his health
and also in order to say let's unite all
together against the enemy the enemy now
it's not only the America the US but
also it's the European Union the
Europeans - - also there's another
message for the West what they call the
West it's we are not weak don't
underestimate us it's true that we had
so many bad luck lately but also we can
hit any time and anywhere when we want
we're still strong
don't underestimate Iran I think this is
was the missed the main message for the
international pressure
okay so came across with a very strong
message we saw though those images of
the protests in Iran do you think this
is going to be enough to take the
pressure off the supreme leader I will
explain it very simply and then you will
understand exactly how it works in Iran
basically it's a supreme leader he is he
has the main power in Iran the supreme
leader is elected by something called
Assembly of Experts
under this umbrella comes for example
the president and also members of the
Parliament the Assembly of Experts they
are appointed by something called the
Guardian Council the Guardian Council
whose members are appointed by the
Supreme Leader so now you can understand
a little bit the power is is totally in
the hand of the supreme leader which is
homina he has the last say when it comes
to military actions he has the last say
when it comes to political decisions and
also economical decisions and basically
some protesters that they asked for him
to step down based on some reports from
Iran they are now most of them they are
in jail activists and also protesters so
I don't think this gonna have
and at least now it's it's not gonna
happen in my opinion there are tensions
in Iran what can the supreme leader at
this dude at this point to ease those
tensions especially ahead of elections
in Iran in February basically an Iran is
it's not playing it very hard they're
playing it smartly when it comes to
politics if I want to talk about the
nuclear deal for example they are
threatening European troops through they
are threatening American troops also
true but also they are opening a door
for any negotiation now based on which
terms I have no idea we have to wait and
see how the negotiation
behind-the-scenes they are going to be
but also don't forget we are not talking
about only confrontation military
confrontation we are talking about also
cyber attacks when it comes between Iran
and also the u.s. he is concentrating
the Supreme Leader is concentrating on
the most domestic opinion now this is
why we saw him today and also his
opening another door for diplomacy when
it comes to the West the US and also the
European so we are expecting something's
gonna happen before the elections in
Iran soon all right t matter Haney from
DW Arabic thank you for sharing your
analysis with us thank you for having me
well earlier this week Germany France
and Britain triggered the so-called
dispute resolution mechanism on the Iran
nuclear deal and that move could
eventually lead to the end of the deal
and a return to sanctions now Germany
has confirmed media reports that the
u.s. earlier pressured the European
Union to take action against Iran by
threatening to impose tariffs on imports
of European cars
let's bring in DW political
correspondent Simon Young for more on
this story hi Simon what do these media
reports say and what do you make of this
so sue me this all comes from a report
in The Washington Post earlier this week
that as you say Donald Trump applied
pressure to the European partners in
this Iran nuclear deal and that is to
say Germany France and Britain by saying
that he was ready to impose punitive
tariffs up to 25 percent for instance on
European car imports to the US now
the question of whether those that
threat was made has been discussed much
today but the government position is
that no pressure had any role in the
German government's decision and the
other European governments as well to
trigger the arbitration mechanism which
is intended they say to sort of get Iran
back on track with the nuclear deal the
jcpoa which as you know has been sort of
abandoned by Donald Trump and the
Iranians have said well you know if the
Americans aren't playing their part then
we won't either
so you know that deal is in peril the
Europeans want to keep it alive if at
all possible so they're saying they took
their decision without any pressure now
as to the question of whether there was
such pressure Spiegel online websites
reporting today that a senior official
in the German Foreign Minister has
confirmed that there was pressure
it seems according to reports that
defense minister and a gret cramped
Karen Baz also acknowledged that there
was such pressure coming from Washington
well the Europeans say that they've been
considering this move triggering
arbitration since the end of last year
but a lot of people are saying well you
know in the end they moved rather
hastily they didn't for instance wait
for a report from the International
Atomic Energy Agency which is looking
into Iran's potential abuses on its
nuclear program so you can make of that
what you will but as far as Berlin is
concerned they say we did not react to
pressure from Washington our politics
correspondent Simon Young thank you